[Applause]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you you guys know
my childhood imaginary friend
the superhero that will help me on my
journeys
as i take far trips to go see my
grandmas
or if we're going to state park like
bear mountain
today i bring you
premium formats sideshows
the flash yo
i can't lie uh
i thought that i would have to go to
custom route in order to get a flash
statue
and i was this close to doing so
so close but then
along came xm and xm got me a flash
statue
even though i was super hyped for it
i wanted a premium format size statue
and sideshow hurt my cries but yo
i'm getting ahead of myself
let me go into
the day i lost my friend
today my imaginary friend
died
let's get into the death of of the flash
crisis on infinite earths episode number
eight
[Music]
it was titled the fate of the flash
that had him beaten up cycle
pirate on the cover
because the flashlight got captured by
the anti-monitor
[Music]
and um i was like this this
is when my man gets free because they
had them all wrapped up
[Music]
and um
he burst free he grabs a
psycho pirate and psychopiraz power is
he
can uh i guess control the minds
of the individuals that look into his
face
and he you know he rips his mask off and
the anti-monitor was trying to destroy
the universe
and he had these centuries
these people that he made these guards
that was helping him guard his machine
that he was building
forming anti-matter machine like a
cannon
and these guards had like a lightning
ability
that they were able to uh throw it at
people
like like a bolt of lightning and they
had a shield
and the flash had uh psycho pirate
around the throat and he ran
to each and every last one of them
and uh used psycho pirates power
to turn those uh
guards against the anti-matter
uh anti-monitor and uh they turn their
weapons against
their boss and the flash proceeded to
beat the brakes
i mean beat the brakes off a psycho
pirate
and um he was asking
him how can he stop the machine and you
know he told him
you know where to go and the flash took
off running
like a real hero he ran into the portal
and when he got there he was in the
housing
the casings the inner casings of the
machine
but right there was all antimatter
and it was basically destroying him
so he took off running counterclockwise
against it
to reverse the current
while he was doing that he felt his
power
leaving him his legs was becoming stiff
and heavy
it was the saddest thing i ever had to
read to be honest with you
for character that i truly loved
and he's running and he's running and
he's going back in time and he's seeing
wally west kid flash and he's seeing a
joker
and he's seeing batman and
all these thoughts is flashing through
his mind
as he literally
ran to death
he turned to bones
and it was nothing left of him except
his costume
and his ring but the machine blew up
i cried as a kid
so hard that day
[Music]
because it was the death
[Music]
of the character that i
i loved
great story george perez
one of my greatest artists
in this lifetime because he can do
individual faces he can do scenes
action scenes like no other
so it's great to know that the great
daniel bell
the sculptor who did this premium format
flash for
sideshow took his turn
[Music]
at this flash
the sensation of speed
coming from this pose
is second to none
second to none
the level of dexterity that he can get
in the fingertips
[Music]
to the hip sway
to the motion of his chest to his
outstretched arms is incredible
now i have the ex edition and
that's the one that comes with mr
freeze's gun
that he has in his left hand
and it you know it has an open-handed
one as well and it comes with
a different air wings ones that
look like lightning bolts and one look
that looks like wings from the comic
books from
the golden era when i used to read
the detail on the costume is amazing
it's a mix between old and new
[Music]
and it gives you
the feel of something classic
yet modern
the facial the portrait
is top-notch i cannot state it more
that you would think that it would be a
simple red
but the level of shading and detail on
the muscles
in this statue it sets it apart
from other statues that i've seen that
are in a running pose
remember i have the xm version of the
flash
and it has a lot of things going on
very beautiful but the sensation of
speed
alone with this character
this statue is incredible
the creases that you will get in the
costume
shows speed
[Music]
the outstretched arms the flex in the
calf muscles
down to the boots to the floor
on the concrete being lifted up
[Music]
shows pure speed
[Music]
well this is the part of the video
where i'm gonna ask you to like follow
and subscribe
and hit that joy button hit that joy
button
you know where that joint button is that
join button is right there at the bottom
hit that join button so you can join the
realm so you can see all the exciting
things that we
have going forward also watch lord
cognito
with the last word lord cognito and
ibontis
is doing fantastic things with the last
word
go to lordsofgaming.net if you want to
know the dimensions of the statue
the background and how much this statue
costs and where you can purchase it from
you see i'm not going to bore you with
boring details
about dimensions and this and that we
have a whole website for that
so you can go to the website you can get
all the dimensions
and you can see if it fits your display
unit
well stick around watch this statue in
all his glory
and next week
i have something something
a little special for you stay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
collected
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you